most of the price increases we've seen
are were expected and expected to be
temporary i don't know anybody including
larry summers who's a friend of mine
who's worried about inflation talk of
inflation
the overwhelming consensus is going to
pop up a little bit and then go back
down
no one's talking about
this great great thing it's on highly
unlikely that's going to be long-term
inflation that's going to get out of
hand there's nobody suggesting there's
unsex inflation on the way
do you take any responsibility or
policies i think our policies help not
hurt
think about what they say
the vast majority of the
of the uh
of the economist
think that this is going to be a real
tough problem to solve but it's not
because of
spending
we brought down the deficit the bottom
line is how much
does america owe
how much in the whole are we going where
are we
how you doing people it is june 1st
2022 that's right everybody it's
lgbtq plus pride month and happy
rainbow month to you
uh if you're out there and you want to
celebrate the month properly uh
obviously paint a rainbow all over
yourself if you see a gay person walking
down the street go up to the gay person
you should bow to the gay then you
should ask them where the closest atm
machine is and give them your life
savings that is what equity and social
justice are all about all of the
companies will be rainbowy all month
this is the month of tolerance and
diversity everybody it's very very
exciting so
get a little gay this month
the whole thing's so stupid it's just so
stupid i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message and we got a jam
packed show
for you today but tomorrow's the big day
i'm in orlando with governor ron
desantis there are about i said six
tickets left there there are about four
tickets left now that's what i'm being
told they're all in the back row that's
all we can offer you that's what's left
people uh tomorrow june 2nd at the plaza
live in orlando in disney country
if you want those last tickets you can
go to davereuben.com
events i'm going to give about a
45-minute talk then the governor and i
will sit down for a 40 45 or so and
we'll see what happens we'll see what
happens i'm not going to plan it too
much it's just we're going to let it be
i'm hearing that there's going to be
some some protests some of the disney
purple-haired people are going to be out
there look forward to seeing them and
then on the third we've got a big
reuben report locals community breakfast
i'm footing the bill for breakfast for
everybody and if you want to join us for
that you can check out more information
at reubenreport.locals.com
today we are going to be talking about
that little uh cold open we just did
there the nonsense the utter nonsense
by the elderly gentleman pretending to
be president joe biden and his
administration his clown car
administration of people who have
consistently got everything wrong but
for them fortunately they have democrat
privilege which is the privilege to
constantly get everything wrong either
intentionally or not and never get fired
never get punished never have the media
call you out uh so we're gonna start
really with uh elon musk who's just had
it with the democrats he's going all in
and and i think it's like this is like
street fighter right now or mortal
kombat choose your fighter do you want
the guy who's sending us to mars do you
want the guy who's built in electric
cars do you want the guy who's fighting
for free speech or do you want a bunch
of bureaucratic buffoons who just want
your money and your attention and all of
that stuff pick a side people the time
is here because inflation is getting out
of control and either you think that
government bureaucrats and middlemen
who've never accomplished anything can
fix it or you think perhaps human
ingenuity and the individual and new
ways of thinking are the ways to fix it
or perhaps even going back to that that
old c word not that c word not that
other c word capitalism perhaps that's
the way we can fix this oh and last
night i went out to dinner with this guy
you might remember this guy remember
that that's jp that's jordan peterson
had dinner in miami last night and we're
going to be doing some podcasts and some
special stuff live in july so stay tuned
for that okay before we get to biden the
uh inflation situation and the
ridiculous not only the ridiculous
response from the administration but the
way the media tries to cover it up and
then they get to the point where they
can't cover it up so then they kind of
begrudgingly have to tell you something
true every now and again uh but before
we get to that let me talk to you real
quick about real estate agents i trust
you know buying or selling a home is
already stressful
it's one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be 10 times worse
if you're not working with the right
agent generally speaking our homes are
our biggest investment that's a lot of
responsibility and you need an agent who
can take that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
founded by my good buddy glenn beck they
work with only the best agents in the
market they do their homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
the network and here's a big one we i
can just say we because i work with
glenn too we only work with full-time
professionals no part-time or
inexperienced agents their team makes
the intro and then follows you through
the buying or selling process to make
sure that you're satisfied the agents
they work with have long track records
and are the best sellers in their field
they're part of this audience they share
your values and they're almost anywhere
you want to go including the free state
of florida the process is simple just go
to real estate agents itrust.com and
provide them with some basic info the
team will contact you to make an intro
to the preferred agent in your town then
you see what happens all right now back
to me okay so why does elon musk who is
the tony stark of reality the guy who is
inventing more stuff
than anyone else the guy who's sending
us to mars and who's doing neurolink and
who's building tunnels under los angeles
the guy who's actually making things
happen
why does he no longer want to be a
democrat well there's a whole bunch of
reasons we've been talking about them
for the last month but a few things have
happened in the last couple days so on
memorial day just two days ago
elon tweeted out this and there was an
interesting response to it so it was a
simple straightforward tweet he said in
remembrance of those who fell to
preserve the light of freedom okay
pretty straightforward then a random
person responded with this
he said you don't care this is just a
random and this is what twitter is all
about for those of you that are not on
twitter what twitter is all about is
random anonymous people with ridiculous
names uh always responding to people
with millions and millions of followers
you don't care about freedom elon if you
did you wouldn't be supporting donald
trump now come back to me for a second
before we get to elon's response because
that's where it gets interesting uh
first off elon has not said he is
supporting donald trump actually he and
donald trump have sparred quite a bit
and even when elon announced just a
couple weeks ago that he was gonna buy
twitter trump went on truth social his
version of twitter to basically mock
elon for doing it saying it's a stupid
business decision and everything else so
elon at no point although he has said
he's leaving the democratic party
although he has said he is voting for
republicans although he has gone after
democrats quite extensively although
he's basically as i said a couple weeks
ago he's completing my life's work
leaving the left and then going to the
promised land um in no way has he said
he is a donald trump supporter so this
is just a random person who says that
but then elon responded and here's where
it gets interesting he said i support
free speech but not any one candidate in
fact i gave money to and voted for
hillary and then voted for biden however
given unprovoked attacks by leading
democrats against me and a very cold
shoulder to tesla and spacex i intend to
vote republican in november
now this is pretty interesting because i
think there's a lot of reasons not to
vote for democrats i've gone into them
quite extensively over the last few
years of my life i think most of you
guys get it the progressives have
completely ransacked whatever was left
of a sort of sane liberal democrat party
there there are no centrist democrats at
this point you if you're a centrist
democrat with the exception maybe of of
joe manchin and kirsten cinema in effect
you're a republican at this at this
point but what's also interesting about
this is as elon musk creates right
creates electric cars sends rockets into
space builds these underground tunnels
does neural like all of this incredible
stuff that he's doing uh the government
is putting up roadblocks all along the
way the government which does not build
anything well does not do really
anything well it does things that are
very expensive and things that are very
cumbersome but it very rarely innovates
well when's the last time the government
innovated anything it just doesn't so
here's a couple of reasons that he's
fighting with them specifically uh
related to tesla and spacex this is from
forbes just a couple months ago a few
hours before tesla reported record
profit and sales for 2021 president joe
biden met with the company's biggest
competitors at the white house to
applaud their efforts with tesla ceo
elon musk notably absent the tech
billionaire later took to twitter to
attack biden he unloaded on the
president on thursday after biden posted
a tweet with gm's mary barra starts with
a t ends with an a esl in the middle
musk wrote following it up with insults
biden is a damp sock puppet in human
form he tweeted biden is treating the
american public like fools so what's
fascinating about this is look i have
come to the belief that at this point
the democrats are intentionally crashing
the economy they want to get us off
fossil fuels so they want to lead us all
to their green new deal they want to
lead us all to electric cars etc etc
elon musk and tesla are by far and away
heads
and tails beyond and in front of
everything else in that in that
department i have a tesla
it is awesome i just over the weekend i
drove across florida across alligator
alley it is the most fun thing to drive
it's so innovative and awesome and cool
and you go to the supercharger station
and you fill it up real quick blah blah
i don't have to sell tesla on you but
the point is that as they are trying to
get us all off fossil fuels as they're
telling us that everyone should get an
electric car what does biden do instead
of inviting the guy who is innovating at
the highest level bringing tesla's out
to the market right and has been doing
it for years instead of inviting him to
the white house he invites all their
competitors so he's saying i don't like
you we the administration don't like you
because you do not bow to us and then
elon's basically saying you suck that's
where we're at with that so now let's go
to spacex this is from september 2021
cnbc after spacex completed a historic
private space flight on saturday ceo
elon musk took a pot shot at president
joe biden who had yet to remark on the
company on the companies and the
civilian flight crews accomplishments
one of musk's 60 million followers on
the social networking platform twitter
asked him the president of the united
states has refused to even acknowledge
the four newest american astronauts who
helped raise hundreds of millions of
dollars for saint jude what's your
theory on why that is musk replied he's
still sleeping so now think about this
again elon musk rockets into space is is
nasa doing much these days could nasa
even get us back to the moon at this
point do you think the government is
hiring the best of the best when it
comes to engineers and scientists and
everything else of course not they're
all going to private companies it is a
dream of anyone that is a true scientist
at this point if you're a true engineer
you're a rocket scientist whatever you
might be is your goal like man i want to
work with the best of the best over at
the united states government
in a in a fluorescent room with green
floors or do i want to work at spacex or
do i want to work on the neurolink
project uh et cetera et cetera or on
gene splicing or any of the other things
that have nothing to do with anything
that the government is competent at so
again it's like here he goes he sends a
rocket out to space pretty cool
astronauts out there again nasa's not
doing much these days not a word from
the white house the white house because
they seemingly only want people that do
things through the government
kind of is
afraid of elon musk i would say
legitimately afraid of elon musk uh here
is uh elon musk at the all in podcast
they had their big event in miami last
week and uh this is david sacks and a
bunch of the other guys uh they have a
great podcast and here's elon basically
ripping into biden the federal
government and just what they're doing
to the economy did you see uh jeff's
uh bezos's tweet back and forth with
biden
where biden i think was talking about
inflation inflation but then he
correlated that to taxing corporations
and bezos said this is misinformation
and disinformation et cetera et cetera
what do you what do you think about that
whole exchange then back and forth
i mean the obvious reason for inflation
is that the government printed a zillion
amount more money than it had uh
obviously um
so it's like the government can't just
issue checks far in excess of revenue
without there being inflation um you
know velocity money held constant and if
if there are more dollars created then
increasing the goods and services output
of the economy then you have inflation
if the government could just issue
a
massive amount of money and have a and
deficits didn't matter then why don't we
just make the deficit 100 times bigger
okay an asterisk can't because it will
basically turn the dollar into something
that is worthless and various countries
have have tried this experiment multiple
times it's not like oh i wonder what
happens if this if this is done yeah
have you seen venezuela the true economy
is the output of goods and services it's
not money
that's a good line the true economy is
the output of goods and services it's
not money meaning if the government can
just print money right and deficits mean
nothing then money doesn't mean anything
it's the stuff we actually produce and
that really is the crux of why this guy
is now at odds with the united states
government the united states government
which does not produce anything and
which in the last year and a half has
crushed the supply chain and as i've
been telling you guys because we just
moved in the last couple months we're
trying to do a bunch of renovations at
the house before the kids arrive and
we're trying to baby-proof the house and
change out a bunch of things yesterday i
was at a a place to get you know
new stove uh new microwave etc
everything six eight months they were
talking into 2023 to get certain things
that's what's happening because the
government has screwed up so many things
on top of the fact that the prices are
so high and now the newest thing is that
used things in some cases cost more than
new things because at least you can get
the used things so people are willing to
pay a premium so that they can actually
get the stove that they want or whatever
it might be so that they can get it this
week as opposed to waiting a year from
now so actual things are what drive the
economy not just that the government can
just print more money because of course
the more money you just print the less
that the money will actually be worth so
why am i talking about all this well i'm
talking about all of this because every
now and again someone comes around who
just pulls back
that curtain and just says boy that oz
guy who you thought was all-powerful and
all-knowing he's actually not that scary
he's some washed up old wizard and
that's the phase that we are in right
now and the machine itself the media is
having trouble
actually keeping the curtain in place so
elon musk is doing great this is not to
worship elon musk by any measure i have
no doubt that i have political
disagreements with him it's just sort of
irrelevant but the point is that the
biden economic policies are leading a
guy who is trying to innovate trying to
do what america is all about to say i
can no longer be part of the democrat
party and this is why i am going to have
to vote republican and by the way
perhaps that will be the moses moment
right moses led the hebrews out of egypt
maybe that will be the moses moment
we've been waiting for where enough of
the remaining sane democrats whatever is
left in that sliver are like finally i
can vote for those scary conservatives
and republicans okay so
uh here is an nbc report on inflation
and everything going on related to that
because they're starting to have to
cover this stuff even though a whole
bunch of us were talking about a while
back even nbc the mainstream media the
corporate press they're finally catching
up we've got problems our recent nbc
news poll showed just 33 percent of
americans approve of the president's
handling of the economy just paying for
basics like rent is a constant worry for
single mother of two kiara age within
the next couple weeks me and my kids
could possibly be on the street because
you know the prices of everything keep
going up her rent in nevada just went up
25 percent it's a lot like i try not to
get emotional about it but it's it's a
heavy load to carry back at the white
house president biden has been rattled
by his sinking poll numbers and is
pressing aids for a more compelling
message and sharper strategy to address
inflation and improve his political
standing people close to the president
tell nbc news
one democratic lawmaker said the white
house has failed to put forward an
intellectually honest plan to combat
inflation well hot diggity damn the
corporate press actually addressing what
we all know what we're all seeing in our
life now what's interesting there what
is the what does the white house want to
do they want to get a more compelling
message out there boy we've really
screwed up this whole thing and we can't
have people knowing that can we fix the
messaging that's really what they're all
about instead of actually doing anything
because what would you do
if you wanted to actually fix the
economy instead of rejiggering the
entire economy and saying okay we're
going to get off fossil fuels we're
going to make everything green and we
can have some discussion about what
legitimate ways there are to do that
that might be environmentally helpful
and also economically not destructive
right we can talk about that but that's
not really what they want to do what
they always want to do is print money
what they want to do is raise taxes on
everybody make it harder to own
businesses defund the police so that if
you own a business your windows might be
smashing all of those things what would
you actually do what would really be the
west best way to get the economy going
right now it is so obvious and so easy
and that's why it's never discussed you
know what you do
you'd cut government spending and you'd
cut taxes period how about we cut taxes
on literally every single person in the
united states everybody i'm just i'm
literally just throwing this out there
crazy dave with one of his crazy
proclamations how about we cut taxes 25
on every single person every single
person across the board federal state
local whatever it might be you're gonna
have 25 percent more money to do
whatever you want with do you think that
might get the economy going because then
people would start spending more money
again and as people spend more money
than the prices of things because
there's more economic activity might go
down but they'll never do that right
they'll never do that what they'll say
is oh we'll print more money we'll
somehow give you more money or if we
could just punish billionaires more
they'll never talk about their own
spending how about we just starve the
beast that's the answer but the beast
always wants more rancor monster always
has to have more gamorean guards that's
a good that was for you michael you got
that one gomorian you like that one too
all right uh here's some info on what's
going on with inflation and prices this
is from statista in april 2022 prices
had increased by 8.3 percent compared to
april 2021 according to the 12
month percentage of change in this
consumer price index respectively the
monthly inflation rate for goods and
services in the united states that's a
lot it's that in essence means almost 10
percent you're paying almost 10 percent
more for stuff than you were
last year and we all know it again this
isn't where you need statistics just go
and buy a package of chicken
just go and buy a shirt or i can tell
you as right now we're trying to buy
cribs and carriages and strollers and
all of those things just go and try to
buy anything i'm trying to do some
landscaping go and try to buy plants at
home depot and you will see the prices
of everything but what the
administration does is lie about
everything and it's not just joe who
often is lying or just confused right
there's also this kamala harris woman
again this is a woman who was polling at
zero in her own party she got the vp
nomination because she's a black woman
that's what joe said himself don't call
me a racist uh here's what she tweeted
out a day or two ago she said since
january of last year the economy has
added more than eight million jobs
businesses have reopened their doors
schools are back in person and while
there is more work to be done we have
made real progress in getting our
economy back on track now this is a
complete
lie this is a complete lie
and here's cnbc debunking that very lie
the economy and this is an important
point hasn't added one single job from
the 2019 high watermark not one all the
jobs that we have seen gained are
recovered jobs that were lost we are not
yet producing new jobs in fact we're
still about nearly four million jobs
short
you get that that's the difference
between recovered jobs
and new jobs right recovery jobs and
adding jobs kamala said we added jobs no
because if you went back to 2019 when
the economy was chugging along and
things were going real well and there
was this orange guy what was his name
again it started with the t sort of the
t uh trump this trump guy was president
remember him with the crazy hair and
everything and he was always eating
mcdonald's and with the ketchup and the
well done steak that guy was president
things were going great and then of
course kovid came and then the democrat
riots and all that other stuff um so
kamala is lying we did not add more you
can't just if you just wipe out 8
million jobs and then you get those 8
million jobs back
that's not adding jobs that's just
getting back what you wiped out that is
what you did there so even cnbc is
debunking the absolute lies of kamala
harris uh here's a little uh video
compilation what's going on over at cnn
and we've got treasury secretary janet
yellen this woman has just screwed up
everything but with that democrat
privilege you never get fired and you
never have to resign
it wasn't just the president who got it
wrong a year or so ago i want to play
for you what you said about inflation
last year listen to this
is there a risk of inflation
i i think there's a small risk and i
think it's manageable i don't anticipate
that inflation is going to be a problem
but it is something that we're watching
very carefully
was it a mistake madam secretary to
downplay this inflation risk
did that contribute to the problems
we're all seeing right now
well um look i i think i was wrong then
about
the path that inflation
um would take the white house concede
that the fed calling inflation
transitory was a mistake
i think the white house concedes that
them also calling it transitory was a
mistake because you saw it's not just
president biden his top economic
advisers also treasury secretary janet
yellen who earlier tonight told wolf
blitzer
that she was wrong to call it transitory
when she said that inflation had posed
only a small risk that was something
that you heard not just from experts
outside the administration but
repeatedly from officials here at the
white house i hate to tell anyone to be
on twitter you guys all know my feelings
about twitter but when the white house
was coming out with that inflation is
transitory i mean it's just going to be
this little thing for now and then it's
going to go away every sensible person
on twitter was saying this is complete
nonsense and we're going to find out
that it's complete nonsense in a month
or two but notice biden we showed you
the cold open talking about inflation
saying it's not going to happen or it'll
be temporary or transitory whatever or
yelling transitory inflation nobody gets
fired nobody gets blamed
think about your own life for a moment
so i run a business here right i have a
production company that runs this show i
have a business manager who handles most
of our finances and i've got a producer
over there sitting there who handles the
production of the show they're
responsible for making sure that
everything is working properly and that
the budgets make sense and we can do the
things that we want to do and we can
produce the content we want to produce
etc etc if i found out that they were
spending far more money than we had or
that they were cooking the books or they
forgot to carry the one that's a big one
uh i would probably fire somebody
michael i'm looking at you you could be
in a lot of trouble um
so that is the point nobody gets fired
but i think in their world they're
writing it off they just don't know what
a write-off is but they're the ones who
are writing it off there's a little
seinfeld for you um
you get the point they can they all just
fail up and they don't actually produce
anything but what's interesting is
there's been a little shift in the
mainstream media they're starting to ask
the right questions right so i try to
give credit where credit is due wolf is
kind of addressing the right question
with janet yellen and here's cnn uh kind
of admitting that uh maybe this has a
little something to do with biden and
his policies
road trips are going to be way more
expensive this summer we now have nine
states where the average is four dollars
and ninety cents a gallon or higher the
latest being arizona illinois and new
york california now stands at six
fifteen a gallon as pete mentioned the
national average 462 a gallon that's up
44 cents from a month ago the problem is
that supply just cannot keep up with
really strong demand as people travel
more
the problem is that supply can't keep up
with demand well it was keeping up with
demand until joe biden became president
and we do know this has nothing to do
with ukraine because in the year that
biden was president before ukraine and
russia gas still went up a dollar a
gallon we've covered that many times but
they're at least addressing there are
some problems right now and things are
expensive and people are gonna have to
spend more on their road trips and
everything else here's abc's jonathan
carl talking about inflation and he
doesn't want to admit it but he sort of
has to
if you look at the numbers uh
inflation
really started to rise almost exactly
when when when biden came in the white
house now obviously that argues my point
doesn't it
but but but but look at the look at this
chart on gas prices uh just since
february if if you look at the i mean
it's it is a
it is a shocking increase that
you know doesn't correspond
you got to love it like they're just
such activists that even as he's saying
about something
like they're just so awful but they they
cannot hide the truth when it's so
obviously right in front of you right
that's the thing so now let's shift over
to what the uh administration and what
the white house is saying about all this
this is a spectacular compilation you
guys know this new white house press
secretary karine jean-pierre she's a
black lesbian
she
it's pride month people i'm trying to
give credit where credit is due okay
spectacular black lesbian one of the
best she is one of the top five black
lesbians that we have in america right
now uh here she is a little compilation
explaining uh what the white house is uh
doing about all this inflation stuff is
it a problem is it a hardship is it a
crisis what is it that people are facing
it is we're just in a difficult time
right now with this inflation that's why
he's doing everything that he can does
president biden take any responsibility
for
his policies potentially contributing to
inflation his policies has helped the
economy get back on his feet that's what
his policy has his policies has done
this
when we talk about the gas prices right
now this is indeed putin's gas hike this
is what we have seen in the most recent
months of of what we've seen at the gas
pump and in some places in this country
now
a gallon of gas costs more than people
on the federal minimum wage are making
in an hour
what does the white house want these
people to do to stop driving to work
look the president
understands what it feels like
dees just spoke about this brian diese
was just here and talked about how he
understands what it means for people who
are sitting at their kitchen table and
see gas prices go up he understands that
feeling personally or seeing prices of
grocery store of grocery groceries go up
in the grocery all right first off
before i address anything she said there
i you know right before i brought that
clip out i said that she's a top five
black lesbian my guys did some googling
as we were showing that so we want to
list out some other black lesbians and
and you decide it's not really for me to
say who a top five black lesbian is but
we got a couple other black lesbians
here we got linda bellows i have no idea
who that is angela davis i don't know
who that is
storm de la vare i don't know who that
is jackie k i don't know who that is are
you just making up names what is this uh
oh lori lightfoot glory lightfoot
definitely a top five black lesbian
audra lorde i don't know who that is and
wanda sykes i do know wanda sykes
comedian want to psych so i think it's a
fair statement to say you know i know
the fact checkers and the disinformation
people are going to be all over me she's
not a top five black lesbian but i think
by what i just read there she absolutely
is as per the content of what she said
right there i mean a couple great lines
we're just in a difficult time
you know guys the the shit's hitting the
fan
what do you want us to do about it his
policies has helped the economy get back
on his feet uh no it's actually done the
reverse of that uh and finally uh joe
biden
he understands what it feels like
i mean the guy does not even know where
he is so the point is she's just
repeating it's just drivel it's just
driveless nonsense and speaking of
driveless nonsense here is biden's
director of national economic of the
national economic council brian deeths
defending their economic policies look i
think that the the what the president
has done uh with respect to
communications has been is been to
consistently uh explain to the american
people where we are and where we need to
go
uh and that continues to be uh the way
that that he approaches this issue and
very much from the perspective of what
it feels like to sit around a dining
room table or a kitchen table
in
in this country because that is that's
his lift experience and that's the way
that he approaches these economic policy
questions and so he understands that
right now the top issue on people's
minds
is prices prices at the
gas station prices of the grocery store
and he's made very clear and he's
communicating very clearly that that's
his top economic priority
guys guys don't freak out don't sure you
can't get baby formula sure everything's
super expensive you can't fill up the
tank with gas
food prices going crazy joe biden's
lived experience this is a guy who has
uh sat at the table okay he has sat at
the dining room table and the living
room table so he knows what's what
you're going through okay dining room
and living room if there's a table and a
chair joe biden has sat on it so he
knows what's going this idea his lived
experience you absolute clowns this is
what i mean about these are just
bureaucratic buffoons who all they do is
read poorly written scripts they cannot
accomplish anything they just they
deserve none of our certainly of our
money but they don't deserve our respect
or our attention or anything else so now
what do we do here at the reuben report
we try to give you some solutions so
what should you do and what should you
be convincing your friends to do well
don't listen to me let's listen to that
elon musk fella
i would class myself as a moderate and
you know neither republican or nor
democrat um and in fact i have voted
vote overwhelmingly for democrats uh
historically overwhelmingly like i'm not
sure
i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear right now
now this election i would
but this election i will he will vote
republican as i often say ladles and
jelly spoons you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a democrat
and at this point you may as well be a
republican there is one political party
that is showing an ability to have a
wide tent to have diversity of thought
to have people who disagree on issues
respectfully and have that battle have
that fight over ideas and what policy is
and it doesn't mean they're all right
and often republicans fail on a
gajillion other things and plenty of
republicans like mitt romney just voted
to give 40 billion dollars to ukraine
but they're a hell of a lot better than
the socialists and communists and
progressive maniacs who have taken over
the democrat party and with that in mind
because i am a man of my word let's show
the image
just the other day
that's it i took that picture as i
officially finally got my florida
driver's license and you know what i did
right there i clicked the second row
that second little
little button right there and i am
officially
a registered republican in the free
state of florida and i have to tell you
as someone that has only been a
registered democrat for my entire life
since i was able to vote and then
eventually i was independent i felt very
proud doing it it's not that
it's a signal like i'm always going to
vote republican because if you say to a
political party hey i'm a registered
this i'm always going to support you
then they have less reason to do
anything for you this is a case where
perhaps i don't like the word community
but the black community might look at
the democrats and be like boy we always
vote for you say 92 to 95 percent we
vote democrat and you guys never really
do anything for us do you think there
might be a connection there we're going
to support you no matter what you do
we got a problem my feeling in in this
registration was that i am a very very
proud floridian right now we have a
fantastic not only do we have a
fantastic governor obviously uh but
mayor here in miami and officials all
over the state and our
the entire apparatus which is now as uh
it's just a matter of fact that florida
has become very red and desantis is
going to crush it obviously and you know
when desantis got into office and he
only won
uh when he ran for governor the first
time by about 30 000 votes and it turned
out that the guy
who he ran against what was the guy's
name again
the guy who lost to desantis it turned
out that he was a meth addict having
orgies
not that there's anything wrong with
that but the point is that that's how
close even florida was to the abyss um
but when he desantis ran the first time
there were about 30 000
more oh no there were 200 000 more
democrats registered in florida than
republicans and last i heard in the last
couple of months it's about 40 000 more
republicans that's a massive shift
andrew gillum was the meth addict having
the orgies that almost became governor
by the way um i really i just want to
reiterate that i stand by the top five
black lesbian thing uh all right stick
around for a cold close we got for you
let me get to a couple locals comments
real quick daphne says angela davis is a
member of the communist party of the usa
uh if she was very notorious back in the
70s oh yes yes yes famous 70s communist
black lesbian angela davis i thought it
was maybe somebody who guest appearance
on the jeffersons or something uh patty
says what planet are these people on
biden has taken this country so far off
the rails yeah he really has he really
has and that's why again they don't
deserve your attention your money your
respect and you should focus on local
things and things that you can control
uh np says dave and jordan need to start
a remake of butch cassidy and the
sundance kid yeah that's right we
definitely have like we had i was just
said
such a great night we did eat steak i
promise you we ate the steak uh if you
want to play along during the live chat
of course you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with dinesh d'souza is up on
youtube last i heard it the full thing
uh is up of course on uh locals and on
rumble because they ain't gonna censor
us
and uh to sum this all up
i enjoyed today's show uh here is the
man who has done this to all of us
joe biden
mr president why do you think there is
uh
[Applause]
you let's go come on let's go thank you
thank you
let's go